foreign
folks welcome to the Dark Horse podcast
live stream number is it 166
767. indeed I'm Dr Brett Weinstein this
is Dr Heather Hein it is uh you know
it's Saturday it is Saturday we've come
to you with another Prime numbered
episode and it is our third year
anniversary of doing these live streams
and uh we're gonna say just a little bit
more about that after we get through all
the top VR Logistics but we're going to
talk to you a little bit about today
we're going to come back with uh a
slight update on the raccoon dog story
we talked about last last week and
raccoon dogs are unaltered but the story
has moved ahead a bit yes
um yes as far as I know they're
unaltered I don't know I didn't
interview any of them
nor did I do the animal behavior on them
I actually did see a I don't know what
the origin of it was but somebody did
place online a brief interview with a
raccoon dog who um was it Brendan
it was a bizarre interview in which the
dog did make the correct argument that
in fact it was slated to be eaten and
therefore was entitled to spread
whatever it wanted
um but anyway I have digressed is this a
complete farce or
or did you actually see something I am
reporting I am reporting I'm not
compelled that this was an actual
raccoon dog nor that the words were um
in fact raccoon dog in origin but I did
see something to this effect
okay I have no idea what's happening uh
so after that uh we're going to talk a
bit about AI
um Brett has a number of things to say
about AI it's doing going back a long
ways right and then we're also going to
talk about uh some things in the trans
universe that have transpired this week
and uh that that will be it but let us
let us get to the top of the hour stuff
first we follow these live streams with
a live q a uh you can ask questions at
darkhorsesmissions.com if you're
watching live you can join the chat at
Odyssey and it's odysse
you know is it two s's
I don't even know I know it's not
spelled the way Odyssey is spelled but
I'm it's o-d-y-se-e okay
um you please consider joining me at my
sub stack Natural Selections uh last
week to I wrote how Now cal of brown and
this week it was Stark and exposed a uh
a
slight Adventure into modern agriculture
not agriculture not at all modern
architecture and the ways in which uh
the the movement that included
um the corbusier and and gropius and
such actually very much mirrors and was
part of the post-modernism that took
over so many domains in the mid 20th
century
so
so that's that's in Natural Selections
this week which I encourage you to to
check out we have of course a store
which is uh run by and The Print Shop is
also owned by a a couple who are just
doing an amazing job and Zach do you
happen to know because I've taken it out
of my notes here what the URL for the
stores is it just Dark Horse store
there darkhorsestore.org so consider
consider checking things out there we've
got things like stickers which you'll
see on the back of my laptop right there
Dark Horse diggers and uh soon or maybe
already pins lapel pins yes and not
lapel but you know any anywhere you want
to wear them really I mean I suppose if
you are someone who occasionally needs
to be shaken vigorously to bring you
back to your senses then you should wear
lapels otherwise it's pretty much up to
you
the question is one of pins well if you
wear them which you could do because
sometimes you need to be Jarred back
into reality or you could just wear them
for stylistic reasons then the pins
would go well on them I remember
um when we were professors and one of
our most wonderful and most frustrating
students who is a very tall and Broad
man like much larger than me uh was uh
just not doing the work that I knew he
was going to do excellently if he would
ever turn it in and and you said to me
you just need to advise them to wear
lapels to class the next time and then
you can reach up and Shake him by them
and uh yes and I don't think it worked I
believe I know exactly who we're talking
about and I believe that later on in our
trajectory through that strange space he
came to class
wearing a t-shirt and a separate set of
lapels that he had he had fashion just
for the occasions knowing that sometimes
people would want grab them by the
lapels even though he towered over
almost everyone he had no Illusions
about himself and he understood that he
did need to be shaken by his lapels
every now and again and wished to
facilitate you know so that's uh it's an
honor to be uh to be respected enough
that somebody would put on lapels in
case you needed to shake them yes did
okay
um we and of course we have Hunter
geather's Guide to the 21st century uh
which uh not only is it available
everywhere books are sold but there is
also signed copies available right here
in the San Juan Islands at darville's
bookstore on Orcas uh which you can
actually go and get signed copies and we
just signed a bunch more this week or
you can order from them that's darvilles
and we are supported by you of course we
appreciate you subscribing liking
sharing both our full videos and the
clips
that are produced on both YouTube and
odyssey and of course we've got the full
audio episodes everywhere everywhere
that you might listen to audio uh you
can also support us by joining us on our
patreons tomorrow at my patreon we have
our monthly private q a so if you join
us there it's it's a smaller group we
actually interact with the chat it's
really a ton of fun and you also have
conversations monthly conversations at
yours so we encourage you to join us
there you can access the Discord server
where they have book clubs and karaoke
and all sorts of fun things and of
course we have sponsors we are very very
grateful for our sponsors we pick and
choose them carefully and we presume
that they pick and choose us carefully
as well and so as always we start these
episodes with three uh with three ads
without further Ado here we go I managed
to find the ad I think time I did hand
it to you oh you did and I had already
buried it but I was able to find it um
in part because my feet are so
comfortable and well taken care of that
I wasn't distracted by any pains that
did help yeah it helps and to what do
you attribute the uh the awesomeness of
your of your feet I attribute it almost
entirely to the fine folks at Vivo
Barefoot juice what a coincidence what a
coincidence they are our first sponsor
uh and they make shoes four feet
everyone should try them and it is
amazing uh most shoes are made for
someone's idea of vivos however are made
by people who have feet and know how to
use them and word is spreading we have
been asked by strangers if the shoes we
are wearing are as good as they have
heard and yes they are
here at Dark Horse we love these shoes
they are Beyond comfortable the tactile
feedback from the surfaces you are
walking on is amazing and they cause no
pain at all because there are no
pressure points forcing your feet into
odd positions which might cause you to
misplace things and not be able to find
them because you were for example
distracted they're fantastic our feet
are the product of millions of years of
evolution
humans have evolved to walk move and run
Barefoot modern shoes that are overly
cushioned and strangely shaped have
negatively impacted foot function and
are contributing to a health and
disorganization crisis because people
move less than they might in part
because their shoes make their feet hurt
enter Vivo Barefoot the Evo barefoot
shoes are designed wide to provide
natural stability thin to enable you to
feel more and flexible to help you build
natural strength from the ground up foot
strength increases by 60 percent in a
matter of months just by walking around
in them and organization improves by 70
percent that is a personal anecdote but
I'm 70 better organized since wearing
Vivo barefoot shoes dude you need to
start wearing them to sleep yeah I need
the other 30 yeah no no I just think
that you still have a long way to go
there's an argument to be made maybe my
gloves are too tight that could be
um the number of people wearing Vivo
barefoots is growing once people start
wearing these shoes they don't seem to
stop I know something that's not
stopping
all right I just got to get through
another paragraph or two and it'll be
fine I mean the fact is that this like
Vivo is one of our oldest or our most
our
her oldest sponsors that sounds wrong um
but we love these shoes and uh and I
think that they can accommodate any
amount of silliness yes
I think they have because you're
attributing your um still abominable but
you are arguing slightly improved
organizations 70 better you just don't
realize it because that 30 I'm not sure
that's a little bummer making up data
during an ad read is actually labeled it
as an anecdote but I will say
it's 70 better which still doesn't leave
me can you operationalize organizational
Improvement for me uh yes let's do that
after the podcast okay okay Vivo
Barefoot has a great range of Footwear
for kids and adults for every activity
from hiking to training and everyday
wear they're a certified B Corp that is
pioneering regenerative business
principles their Footwear is produced
using sustainably sourced natural and
recycled materials with the aim to
protect the natural world so you can run
wild on it go to Vivo barefoot.com and
use the code darkhorse15 to get an
exclusive 15 off
additionally all new customers get 100
day free trial so you can see if you
love them as much as we do that's Vivo
b-a-r-e-f-o-o-t.com and use the code
darkhorse15 at checkout
thank you
our second sponsor this week is Helix
now Helix makes fantastic mattresses and
they might not want you to wear your
vivos to bed so you're going to have to
sort of do a trade-off do you think that
the Helix mattresses also improve
organization or just the vivos I don't
know it's for you to decide and produce
your own animal there's a trial period
one should not wear shoes on the
mattress during the trial period but
afterwards to say who's who's to say yes
Helix makes fantastic mattresses that
are supremely sleep enhancing it's
amazing what a difference an excellent
mattress can make for good sleep our
animals love it too a little too much
Maddie our Labrador who has left the
building
um is not allowed on the bed and she
knows it but we know that she takes naps
on the new Helix mattress when we're not
around it's just that good
seriously Helix sleep is a premium
mattress brand that offers 14 different
mattresses based on your unique sleep
preferences take the Helix sleep quiz
online in less than two minutes you'll
be directed to which of their mini
mattresses is best for you they sleep on
your back your side your stomach do you
toss and turn or sleep like a log
do you prefer a firmer or softer
mattress all of these are taken into
consideration with the Helix sleep quiz
sleep like a log has never quite struck
me as right yeah logs don't sleep logs
downstairs honestly they just kind of
lay there until they don't at which
point they're not laying there like logs
either okay logs don't sleep but dogs
aren't especially sick and clams aren't
especially happy as far as I can tell so
there's a lot of wiggle room is it that
they
they like if you look
her and it just right it appears that
their smile is sort of like Cheshire
clams
um
I don't think so I think it's people
projecting Happy People apparently happy
people uh sick dog people uh log
sleeping people right however your
preferences in sleep are all taken into
consideration with the Helix sleep quiz
once you've found your perfect mattress
it ships straight to your door free of
charge then you'll have 100 nights to
try it out with any penalty during which
you should not sleep in your shoes if
you love it which you almost certainly
will they've got 10 to 15 year
warranties on all of their mattresses
Helix has models with memory foam layers
to provide optimal pressure relief if
you sleep on your side and walls with a
more responsive thumb which provides
optimal support for stomach and back
sleepers enhanced schooling features
keep you from overheating at night and
every Helix mattress combines
individually wrapped steel coils in the
base with premium foam layers on top
providing excellent support for your
spine and comfort for all of you
Helix has been awarded the rank of
number one mattress by both GQ and Wired
Magazine and we can see why Helix
mattresses are made in America at their
very own manufacturing facility they're
built for human bodies and built to last
Helix also supports military First
Responders teachers and students by
giving them a special discount on site
we look forward to archelics Mattress
providing some years of excellent sleep
you should look forward to yours doing
so as well Helix is offering up to 20
off all mattress orders and two free
pillows for your list for our listeners
go to helixsleep.com Darkhorse and use
promo code Darkhorse that's Helix sleep
h-e-l-i-x-s-l-e-p.com slash Darkhorse
this is their best offer yet and won't
last long with Helix better sleep starts
now two points of clarification one the
Sleep quiz should be taken while awake
but not driving two when they say sleep
on your side they mean your orientation
rather than sleeping on your side versus
the other person's side which would make
it your side
yep it's gonna be one of those kind of
days I can tell
yes you can after this many years you
should be able to
our final sponsor this week is Maddie's
favorite I mean she likes the shoes just
fine because sometimes when we put them
on that means we're going out for a walk
she likes the mattress a bit too much
but her favorite is Sundays Sundays is
dry dog food
when they approached us when sadness
approached us about being a sponsor we
were dubious Maddie our dog he's absent
at the moment is a labrador frankly I
was going to Brett didn't add recently
for a guest episode in which we staged
it so that you would feed her during the
ad and it was awesome and I was going to
do that but we ran out of Sundays last
night and Maddie is like I'm not showing
up on camera if you don't have Sundays
for me no
we'll see we'll see yeah
but she's a labrador Labs Elite
basically anything what possible
difference we thought was she going to
show an interest between her usual
kibble a widely available high-end brand
and Sundaes well we were wrong Maddie
loves a food that Sundays makes
seriously loves it
um and indeed when we ran out and gave
her some of that other high-end brand
this morning she looked at her Bowl
looked at us sat her butt down and
didn't eat
she wanted her Sundays guess what it is
far better for her than the standard
kibble that comprises most dried dog
food even the high-end stuff Sonny's is
the first and only human grade air dried
dog food combining the nutrition and
taste of all natural human grade foods
with the ease of a zero prep ready date
formula Sundays is an amazing way to
feed your dog and in a pinch a person
too yup I didn't try to feed you with it
you tried to feed you with it best dog
food I ever tried
Sundays
Sundays is easy for humans too no fridge
no prep no cleanup no gross wet dog food
smells
and you may be able to feed your husband
on it
Sundays is gently air dried and ready to
eat
I felt oh yeah it's fine dog food but
you know
try to Taco
a little crunch
it's going a bit far okay yep Sundays is
gently air dried and ready to eat no
artificial binders synthetic additives
or general garbage seriously look at the
label all of Sunday's ingredients are
easy to pronounce except for quinoa and
healthy for dogs to eat in a blind taste
test Sunday's out performed leading
competitors 40-0 I thought that was
going to be a made-up number when I
first saw that too but again here's the
thing when I have a bowl of her previous
food which we still have on hand uh
ready for her she's enthusiastic usually
but once she's been having Sunday she's
not enthusiastic and she always goes for
the Sundays preferentially always she
bounces and she she spins and she does
all these amazing anticipatory
gymnastic leaps in anticipation for the
Sundays and not for the other stuff do
you want to make your dog happy with
your diet and keep her healthy try
Sundays we've got a special deal for our
listeners receive 35 off your first
order go to Sundays for dogs.com star
course or use code Dark Horse at
checkout that's
s-u-n-d-a-y-s-f-o-r-d-o-g-s.com forward
slash Darkhorse switch to Sundays and
feel good about what you are feeding
your dog all right question for you okay
why is quinoa spelled that way given
that the Inca did not have written
language it should just be spelled
phonetically right it's you know we
actually know the person to ask we have
we have a quechua a quechua expert in
our in our sphere I mean everyone does
but yeah so
um
it's always a question when um languages
that weren't written at all or weren't
written in our alphabet are turned into
being spelled into our alphabet often it
feels like why they spell them that way
and sometimes it's going to be about the
way the first person who was being
interviewed about their words was
pronouncing it or the hearing on the
other end or sometimes I feel like it's
just intentionally befuddling but Ellis
Island phenomenon yeah yeah exactly but
yeah quinoa does not seem very much like
quinoa and quinoa yeah miles apart yeah
kilometers per
foreign
so
we've been at this for three years yes
three years and um it feels like two of
those years were this morning already
sometimes sometimes yeah yes sometimes
our very first one was on March 24th
2020. at which point uh the lockdowns
were beginning it was uh it was the Wild
Wild West out there and I don't think we
did or could have predicted half of what
has happened since then but we are as
ever grateful to our audience and to the
you know a remarkable number of people
who get in contact with us
[Music]
yeah that was not none of that was ad
yeah even the discussion about quinoa I
was totally unremunerated yeah our
producer has just returned from the
other side of the border so he's still
there's no excuse yeah
I said border I meant equator actually
lots of borders across lots of lots of
borders only one equator and now I'm
thrown again yeah I can't even get it
right equator border one equator
Crossing multiple border crossings he's
back that wasn't an ad
this is the third anniversary episode of
our Dark Horse live streams you were
doing Dark Horse for
a bit about three uh six months before
that
um but we've been doing these weekly we
started off doing them twice weekly uh
pretty much reliably ever since and it
has been quite a wild ride yeah and I
should say
um Dark Horse uh started as a discussion
program me and one other person uh and
we were doing it from uh studio in
downtown Portland and covet happened
Zach and I grabbed everything we could
pull out of that studio and moved it to
our place and got a lot of stuff from a
hardware store and built the set that we
were on uh the whole time we were in
Portland under lockdown
but that the uh the idea for the live
streams came from you what you said was
we were doing something trying to sort
out what was going on with the covid you
know trying to use our biological
toolkit to make sense of it and you felt
that we really needed to share what we
were doing because everybody was
struggling to figure it out and it might
be useful and uh that was a tremendously
good idea and we know because we run
into people all the time who tell us
what this meant to them during
um the uh the covid period
um that it was the right idea and I'm so
glad that we did it in spite of all of
the
terrible stuff that came back at us in
many regards yeah no it's it's been um
it's been clarifying again you know
there that we had we had
uh and an evergreen moment of scales
falling from our eyes and um and finding
Clarity around both issues and
relationships uh that uh could be
painful but um as I began saying back
then well I'm glad I know yep and once
again that's the case that's the case
throughout cobit as well that as painful
as it can be to realize that people that
the relationships some of the
relationships you have aren't what they
seemed uh and um people don't have the
values that they claim to have um I'd
rather know I'd always rather know and
and that's I mean I think one of the
things that you learn in all of this is
that some people wouldn't rather know
right some people would rather stay in
the dark and and of course just as when
Evergreen blew up that's coming up on
six years now
um
we yeah lost some relationships but
gained so many more that were
extraordinary and we have made some just
amazing both professional relationships
and friendships uh since we've been
doing these live streams and are very
grateful very grateful for that it's
better than that awesome yes is that the
first time you ever said that but not in
life but um you know even better it's
even better than that terrific let's do
it so you said you're grateful to know
yeah and I would go way past that it is
essential that you find out who it is
who can be relied upon under crisis
circumstances because the worst thing
that can happen is you can imagine based
on how people behave under normal
circumstances
um what they're going to do in a crisis
you can be dead wrong and then when the
crisis happens the cost of discovering
that in real time is spectacular so as
terrible as it was to have seen people
that we would have imagined would stand
up under crisis conditions uh fail in
that as you say it's better to discover
it so that you don't put weight on that
ice and the people who you discover in
the crisis the people who shine
sometimes people surprise you or other
times you meet people that you never
would have encountered absent the crisis
and you discover that they are up to the
challenge
um it is a
admittedly painful but it is an upgrade
to the quality of life yes
um so anyway the universe when it puts
you through a crisis and reveals who
can't handle it is doing you a favor and
it is important to realize that that's
what's happening
um as much as it is uh heartbreaking to
to lose people
absolutely so
indeed
um okay and just one uh brief comment
about a story we talked about at some
length last week before you start
talking about excuse me AI is the
raccoon dog research that we discussed
last week and we were
we read a number of bits from the
Atlantic article that had come out and
shared some of the New York Times and
part of our objection was just like with
uh the together trial the results were
promote were were released and promoted
in mainstream media as if they were
scientific findings that everyone could
assess and therefore the fact that they
were out there sort of implies that they
have been assessed by the scientific
Community but there was literally no
paper at all it was there was a there
was a press release I think or you know
maybe just a couple of interviews there
was nothing well that has now changed
kind of so on March 20th just you know
five days ago a couple days after our
last live stream they did and do in dude
um
I'm trying that must mean something but
I don't know
um they did indeed uh post something to
zanotto a pre-print server although they
say they call it a report and they say
quote
um I actually don't have the quote
um they do not intend to publish this
report in a scientific journal
really I wonder why uh well when you
look at the paper you can begin to kind
of see why I have only skimmed it I have
noticed that a lot of other people have
already dug deep and found you know
various various problems with it it's
messy and confusing and pretty long and
and the authors say in their little
Preamble they're not going to publish
this on as a scientific paper like what
does that just give them cover like oh
we put a thing out but well it's not
really the real thing so you know it's
just like it's one faint after another
um and in the near the end of the paper
they say the authors claim that quote
data accumulated since the beginning of
the covid-19 pandemic Point clearly to a
zodiotic origin of SARS Kobe 2.
and then they proceed to make a series
of the weakest arguments I can possibly
imagine I mean it's it's really
remarkable what like the level of
analysis and that they basically don't
expect anyone to check their work like
hey they started by not letting anyone
check their work and now they put
something out where they're like yeah
but it's not really a paper We're Not
Gonna
um We're Not Gonna submit this to a
journal and yet they make these claims
that just sound like the strongest
claims possible
but the actual claims aren't they're
they're insane well in fact they said
this was the strongest evidence yet for
a zoonotic origin this this like finding
some some bits of raccoon dog genome in
the same place as some SARS Kobe 2.
right some really weak circumstantial
evidence that is actually perfectly
consistent with the idea that the Wuhan
Institute of virology is close enough to
the seafood market that people who work
at one are liable to shop at the other
and we know there were stars Kobe too
there and we know there are raccoon dogs
there so this evidence doesn't give us
anything can do it's not evidence and so
what they are doing and we need a name
for this and I at the moment I don't
have one it's somehow
um
it's like uh headline priming or
headline ginning right the whole idea is
to pretend that there is science that
justifies a headline and that the only
it's a it's a it's a data flow problem
where you know the they're gonna put out
the conclusion of the paper and of
course the paper's coming and it will
you know it's basically the bad habit
that uh science folks get into where
they will read the abstract of a paper
and they will not figure out whether the
method section justifies it or the
statistics that were done were correct
or any of those things
um so the idea is you read the abstract
and the whole thing is based on trust
this is like well we're not even going
to give you an abstract what we're going
to give you is the headline you would
write if there was an abstract that was
justified by a paper and then we're not
going to follow up with the paper
because of course the value of the whole
thing is the exercise of producing the
headline and why would you go through
the you know why would you put yourself
at risk of having your headline
invalidated by scrutiny when you could
just allow the headline to float for
good as if a paper had had emerged
um yes this has been going on a long
time by the way yes it has I remember
this from the death of Dolly the sheep
right who was this is going to have been
like late 90s or the odds uh this is
going to be
uh early OTS
and I had a dog in the fight because in
my paper on telomeres I had predicted
that she would die of age-related
pathologies anomalously early and
they said she didn't did they give us a
paper no they said they literally put
out a press release in which they said
that they would do a full necropsy and
they would let us know if they found
anything right which is insane because
at the time that Dolly died she was of
course the oldest mammal clone on Earth
and so a full necrops he doesn't begin
to explain what they should have done
for this animal a they gave the
implausible explanation that they had
put it out of her misery because they
couldn't stand to see her suffer from
the pathology that they swore was not
age related
um but you know okay whatever the cause
of death this animal should have been
thin sectioned one end to the other so
that future researchers could go back
and figure out what was taking place
there necropsy is not the beginning of
what they should have done but anyway my
basic point was there was no paper there
either right right this was a case in
which there was a lot at stake a lot
financially at stake because the patent
on nuclear transferred cloning was
incredibly valuable and its value would
be lower if it caused age-related
pathologies so in any case the the trick
of creating a headline or creating an
impression that scientific work has been
reported but not actually presenting the
work is a uh a tactic that one should
expect to see where there's a great deal
at stake either with respect to
something like covet origins or with
respect to something like a valuable
patent like nuclear transfer cloning and
I would also point out that
interestingly that report on raccoon
dogs it came in advance
of the revelation of a paper that Robert
Malone called Smoking Gun on covet
Origins where basically it reported uh
an experiment in which uh this week in
the last four days yeah uh
um last week somehow but I mean you just
said that this the report here predated
the headline the initial report in which
we all got the word that something
important had happened with raccoon dogs
right preceded by less than a week the
revelation of this published work in
which the enhancement of uh SARS like
coves to become infective of humans was
discovered in the literature so anyway
check out Robert Malone's Twitter and
search for the term Smoking Gun and you
will find that
that research
I'm reminded you can show my screen just
briefly
um this is a article published in Forbes
in 2020 in July 2020 in which they say
you must not do your own research when
it comes to science
and they make they make this argument
that it's just too tough It's too
challenging and you're putting yourself
and everyone else at risk by doing so
then compare that to Zach if you would
give me my screen back for a moment so I
can show
this paper you can now now bring up this
this is this is the report that they say
is not destined for a
for a journal
in which they make introductory remarks
and say among other things
uh
no they say somewhere in here that they
are not going to submit this to a
journal but uh this paper
is oh this report is not intended for
publication in a journal there it is
um they're keep they start with key
points which is sometimes done in an
actual scientific paper but this is
accessible if they would share more
information the likes of which you're
supposed to do in science and
to have this kind of analysis happening
at the same time as granted that Forbes
article is from almost three years ago
but throughout this we've been told
don't ask questions don't do your own
research don't assess for yourself
simply trust the authorities who've
shown up with credentials that you may
or may not be able to assess with
backgrounds and with skills that you may
not be able to assess and don't you know
pay no attention to the man behind the
curtain pay no attention to the fact
that the entire system has been so so
corrupted by the role of money and
federal granting agencies that the vast
majority of people who are now doing
science in the west at least in the US
are doing little tiny reductionist
pieces of Science and will actually say
if you ask them questions outside of
their little domain well that's not my
concern so why would we trust you know
World Health to people who will say no I
just do this thing I just do this little
thing and when you go looking I spend a
little bit of time looking at the
backgrounds of a few of these authors
who you know aren't aren't the ones that
we keep on hearing about and indeed
they're just they're just doing this
narrow you know blinders on science for
their entire careers and where's the
evidence that they actually know how to
assess things I don't find it no and
clearly clearly they don't for them to
put their name to this
um
clearly they don't uphold any such
standard and I will point out so much of
this
uh so much of the
malfeasance here come down to the
application of two different standards
depending upon whether you're on
narrative or off narrative right almost
all of this the things that people who
are dissidents are accused of violating
the sacred rules of science the fact is
those who are on narrative are granted
no end of leeway in the same direction
so
um if you were to Simply apply any
consistent standard you would come out
with a far better answer than we have
and in fact what's happening is you know
somebody is peeking at who it is who is
engaged in work and deciding whether to
Institute an impossible standard that
can't be met or no standard at all so
that you will need it irrespective of
whether what you've effectively done is
published newspaper headline without a
method
um and anyway uh of course this crashes
the world right science is not capable
of you know science isn't a posture it's
not costume right it's also not optional
right and we've taken it for optional
it's like it's it's an affectation for
many people who are columns of
scientists yeah you actually have to do
the method correctly and you have to do
it according to the underlying
philosophy of science where it doesn't
work yeah right the fact that it
involves sciency looking stuff or
science sciencey language has nothing to
do with it people with degrees it
doesn't matter you either did the method
right or you didn't yeah
yeah as long as we spend a little bit of
time here
um
let me just
let me just provide some of their
evidence for their incredibly strong
claims so you can show my screen again
here Zach this is again from the report
um purporting to show the strongest
evidence uh yet that uh sorry Kobe 2 had
a zoonotic origin data accumulated since
the beginning of the covid-19 pandemic
Point clearly towards a zoonotic origin
of SARS Kobe too oh
one a preponderance of the earliest
hospitalized covid-19 patients were
linked to a single location
really
two the locations of early severe Copa
19 cases without a clear epidemiological
link to the market to the Honan Market
nevertheless we're so centered on and
close to the market it is clear that
Community transmission of starscovy 2
began in this local area and only later
expand across Wuhan
incredible incredible of course depends
on a correct start date for the pandemic
oh yeah and they they're definitely
sticking with January you know
january-ish in this paper nonsense um
and it you know it just it's it's all
about the location
almost all of their pieces of evidence
here these strong overwhelming evidence
and then let me just uh
finish with these arguments stand in
stark contrast to the absence of
evidence for any other SARS Covington
the absence of evidence that's
fascinating even in the Genome of the
thing
here here's what they're doing yeah
right
a
this couldn't possibly convince anybody
who's paying attention in detail right
so the purpose of this is to convince
people who are not paying attention that
something has happened that has swung
the pendulum in the direction of natural
origin right yep so
and there's a vast number of people in
that category right these are people who
are you know glued to their New York
Times and haven't understood that it is
a propaganda arm of the government and
who knows what else right these are
people who just need the headline itself
and so the idea that there is like this
cottage industry of generating headlines
that serve the right people's interests
and cause some large percentage of the
audience that isn't doing its own
research in any regard to jump well it
feels like this report not even a
pre-print right because they say they're
not gonna
um
submit it to a journal seems like this
report those bits that I just read are
actually written to be pulled and quoted
by the mainstream media right like this
is not written for scientists it's
written for the media to do pull quotes
and you know I don't I don't know that's
that's a hypothesis it's written but it
doesn't feel that that that little
bracketed argument that I just read part
of
I I cannot remember as as bad as the
scientific literature is I cannot
remember ever seeing anything so
transparently flimsy in the discussion
section which is what that would more or
less be of an actual scientific paper it
actually is the uh private citizen
analog of you know the uh busy scientist
reading abstracts right there is a
citizen that just pays attention to what
the New York Times has concluded right
oh natural origin strongest evidence yet
why that does sound strong on top of
already strong evidence right and well
what you what's that you say there's no
evidence at all for a laboratory origin
fascinating geez I wonder what those
people one side we've got evidence and
on the other side we have no evidence
right and I know which side I like yep
and so you know we certainly saw this
with Ivermectin together trial six
months of looking at a slide from a
presentation without a method and then
when you get the method is of course uh
fraudulent and caps the dosage this is a
trick right the trick the purpose of the
trick is in the New York Times right
it's not to convince anybody who
understands science who is paying
attention to the evidence because it
couldn't it's too thin it doesn't there
is no evidence here right and combine
that with articles like in Forbes in
2020 saying when it comes to the science
do not do your own research right like
really that is that that is literally
the argument coming across the
Transcendent people it is your it is
your civic responsibility to accept what
we say and I would argue and we have
argued many times it's actually your
civic responsibility to do no such thing
it is your civic responsibility to do
the opposite at the point that they tell
you is your civic responsibility just
accept what we say you need to say
actually now I will not yeah not you are
you are inherently wrong because you
said that but now I will explicitly ask
for all of the evidence that you have
laid out in as clear terms as possible
so that I can assess and most of the
people who are being chastised for doing
their own research aren't doing their
own research per se what they're doing
is listening to unsanctioned channels
where people like you and me who did
study biology you know have the relevant
degrees not only a biology degree but
evolutionary biology which is highly
relevant to many different facets of
what unfolded under covid like listening
to us and figuring out whether we're
making sense is a totally reasonable
thing for somebody who does not believe
that they have the toolkit to do the
analysis themselves to do right and then
how would you know if you're being
suckered gee I don't know track record
would that do it right the point is
they're trying to Spook people they're
trying to Poison the Well of well what
would you do if you didn't trust the
official narrative
maybe I would listen to people who work
you know well qualified and also didn't
trust the official narrative see what
they have to say and if they turn out to
be wrong across the board okay maybe
they're not good at it but if they turn
out to be right across the board I'm not
going to make excuses over it right well
all right uh let's segue
to talking about AI yeah all right so
the next Crisis which I um I I'm going
to confess my bent up front and then I'm
going to start us down the road of how
to think about this because I think
unfortunately whether we are interested
in talking about this topic or not it is
about to take over the world in a way
that is going to force us to it rather
like code actually
um though I fear uh as much as I don't
want to hear myself say this I fear that
what is at stake is actually vastly
greater
so here's the uh
the
reason that this is the moment to start
this discussion we have had some weeks
of uh run up months of run-up with chat
GPT 3.5 which was an update of a model
that had some surprising capacity it
said some foolish things there were lots
of things that's where it couldn't do
um but it clearly had a uh large amount
of capability that had uh not been seen
previously in AI circles
much closer to passing a touring test
for example
than than previous previous prototypes
that has now been updated to
chatgpt4 Chachi bt4 is now available
it's got a public interface you can play
with it and it is vastly more capable
not surprisingly than fat gbtree 3.5
this has lots of folks who have been
paying attention either because they're
excited about artificial intelligence or
because they have trepidations about
artificial intelligence or in many
people's cases both
this has their attention because we are
seeing capacities here that are
um nothing if not remarkable and
actually I would point you to this is a
little bit chronologically strange
because a paper has just emerged Zach
you want to show that PDF
a paper has just emerged Sparks of
artificial general intelligence early
experiments with tpt4 now this paper
does not emerge in the short period of
time that chat gbt4 has been available
to the public this is out of Microsoft
research and these researchers have had
months to play with it did this just
come out yeah now they report is it
published or is it uh it is pre-print it
is on the archive
nonetheless it is an extensive paper and
it is a very challenging paper
especially if AI isn't your bag
however I can say it reports a number of
things that definitely got my attention
one of them is that this version 4 of
GPT
appears to do several things that those
of us who are and you know we're going
to come at this as biologists we're
looking at something that's like an
organism we know nothing about and we're
trying to understand what it is and
isn't capable of you know when we look
at an octopus for example we see a
creature that does not have the
characteristics that you would typically
imagine go along with extremely creative
intelligence uh and Consciousness and
yet we see behaviors in an octopus that
tell us that those things at least
belong on the table it's certainly a
highly intelligent animal despite not
having generational overlap and not
being highly social
it solves problems that are unambiguous
it can you know open jars and things
like this
um but you know so we can look at a
creature like that and we can say look
it doesn't you know it's not a it's not
a gorilla where we would expect these
things or an elephant right this is a
creature that doesn't have those
characteristics but it behaves like it
has
um it has these things in its mind
we can look at GPT uh for in the same
way and what we see are a number of
things that ought to get any biologists
attention one of them is it manifests
a degree of
um theory of mind
that is to say if and one of the things
that makes uh gpt4 so
interesting is that an average person
can test it in ways that people may not
have thought to official you know
scientific uh trained scientifically
trained people may not have thought to
query it but you can pose things to it
and you can see how compelling the
answer it puts together is and so one of
the things that's demonstrated in this
paper
is theory of Mind where you can describe
a scenario and then you can you know ask
what this character understands based on
an indirect
um an indirect description and uh it is
at least often capable of giving a
correct response that shows theory of
mind it also is capable of tool use
which is fascinating right so when we
look at an animal you know certainly
there are lots of animals that use tools
right many more than was once understood
we've seen you know things like crows
which are highly intelligent social
creatures use tools to solve puzzles we
of course see chimpanzees use tools
otters use tools I have recently seen
uh otters both using rocks to uh bash
onto shellfish and using shellfish which
they bash onto rocks anyway so tool use
you know is not limited to the most
highly intelligent and presumably
conscious creatures crows engage in meta
tool use even um so I think it's the new
tech new Caledonian crows that have been
observed to basically make tools use
tools to make other tools with which to
accomplish the job they want so you know
just sort of tool use embedded within
tool use yep
um tool use embedded within tool use I'm
also I will just take an aside and say
that I think if you are interested in
the question of what is present in other
intelligent creatures I would advise
people to cautiously
uh point that question at the subreddit
uh I believe it's our animals being
geniuses
now not everything on that subreddit is
a bona fide case of
um
of intelligence some of it is probably
people training creatures I saw uh one
in which a turtle which I would say I
would strongly suspect does not have
remotely the capacity to play
Tic-Tac-Toe in which a turtle
appears to play Tic-tac-toe and win uh
well a it could lose you know 49 games
out of 50 and you could film all of them
and it could win once but I don't think
it can play Tic-Tac-Toe so what I think
is happening is the person has trained
the animal to move to a position on the
tic-tac-toe board you know using some
sort of a stimulus yeah but anyway my
point would be there's lots of stuff on
the subreddit that actually does appear
to be animal solving
um problems in utterly remarkable ways
and you've got to start thinking about
you know is this individual unusually
intelligent even so maybe that says that
that kind of capacity exists in the
creatures but anyway if you take a look
at what you see there and then ask
yourself what you would have what test
you would have to run to figure out
whether or not the example in question
means what it appears to mean or whether
it could be produced by some other
mechanism or could be just lucky in some
cases
but
I will I may I will post this as well so
I finally found
um you can show this Zach if if this is
something you're interested in this is
something we should probably come back
to this is a paper that I used to use um
you might animal behavior program a 2010
paper animal tool use current
definitions and updated comprehensive
catalog so
um you know there will be some anecdotal
accounts here because especially once
you're talking about primates there's
often you know someone even if they
spend hundreds or even thousands of
hours watching a troop they may see one
example of something and uh and that is
that is still an observation even if it
doesn't make for a data set but this is
an extraordinary uh paper that oops
that basically goes through
um you know it's 69 pages long has these
tables of all of the at that at that
point known you know 13 years ago known
examples of tool use across Animalia
right which so yeah an excellent place
to build your model and really you know
I'm not going to pretend to be uh an
expert on AI
what I am as an animal behaviorist as
you are and so thinking about what might
be in the mind of another creature is
familiar territory and uh
[Music]
um
can you give me my screen back please
thank you um
using those tools to understand where we
may be headed is pretty important but in
any case let me um set the stage this
way
I have watched people in my friend group
discussing their own creative uses of
what is newly available
um and
um what I see I do see some trepidation
about it from various circles including
uh amongst people I find very excited
about the growth of this thing but I
I'm actually concerned that in general
those who are prone to see the potential
in this technology
may actually be missing the uh the
problem uh where we are headed and what
I said on uh Rogan the last time I was
on was we aren't ready I don't think we
did any of the legwork necessary for
this and so what I hear from people is
about the amazing potential that exists
here and I agree the potential here is
amazing but I see
um you know you know what else has
amazing potential
a lot of things the cell phone
okay cell phone's gonna be great this is
going to liberate people imagine having
the world's greatest encyclopedia in
your pocket imagine being able to
navigate any city on earth like a native
right imagine being able to access your
entire brand network from anywhere on
earth right the potential here is huge
right you're going to be able to solve
problems I mean you you could be a
handyman you could use this thing to you
know find instructional videos while
you're in the field solving some problem
that you've never seen before the
potential here is great
and it is
on the other hand what is the net effect
of the cell phone been
um some of us think it's been a disaster
right we could say the same thing about
social media oh my God people are going
to be distance no longer means anything
we're going to plug into you know each
other's consciousnesses we're going to
be able to find people we you know want
to participate with it's not going to
matter where they are where you know
it's going to be one flowing ebbing
human culture and Consciousness
Smorgasbord or whatever right
okay it is on the other hand it's been
terrifically deranging and has allowed
the parasitism of people
um because nobody really understands the
algorithms and their effect on what we
think is true so you know again we've
got now two examples here of something
that had tremendous potential to enhance
Humanity but there's a strong argument
to be made that the net effect was
negative right
um in fact one of our friends
um in describing what he saw as the
great potential of the unleashing of
this obvious tool for solving problems
the chat 3pt
um was he was arguing that as this thing
matures that effectively it's going to
be like cognitive capacity too cheap to
meter right that this is in some sense
the end of a kind of scarcity right
um because everybody's going to have
access to now the phrase too cheap to
meter has a an embarrassing history
right that was the argument that was
marshaled for fusion power right that it
was going to produce electricity too
cheap to meter right it was just going
to free us from having any concern about
energy so to the extent that energy
limited our capacity to do cool stuff
wasn't going to be true anymore well
that turned out not to be right right
what's more even to the extent that it
is possible the argument I've made about
about fusion power which I think has
tremendous potential to solve Humanity's
problems is that if you just simply
provided it tomorrow it would make
things worse right that the fact that
you haven't built a structure that knows
how to Dole out access to this thing in
a Fair Way means that it just becomes an
accelerant on the you know the uh
radical asymmetries that that we already
have existing in the system so
My Hope here was to start the
conversation and say look a we have to
talk about a couple of different ways in
which AI can make things worse in order
to know which conversation we're having
so those who are well steeped in uh
existential risk as it's connected to AI
talk about something called the steering
problem right sometimes you will hear
them joke about paper clips and you'll
think why are they joking about paper
clips
um the reason I believe paper clips
forgive me if I'm wrong but I think
Eliza udkowski made an argument in an
old paper of his about AI risk and his
point was
imagine that you had an incredibly
powerful AI that was interested in doing
your bidding
and you decided that you wanted to
make your way in the world by
creating and selling paper clips and you
gave it an instruction like make as many
paper clips as possible right well what
are paper clips made out of oh they're
made out of neutrons protons and
electrons as is everything else in the
universe so imagine that the AI thinks
that what its job is is to take all of
the protons neutrons and electrons in
the universe and convert them into paper
clips and you know Guess What You're
Made Of right so the point is it starts
liquidating the universe and making
paper clips thinking that it's doing the
right thing but the point is your
instruction just sucked
um so that
thinking that it's doing the right thing
isn't it isn't
quite right or at least it's not
necessary at the level that that AI
would be doing it right there there is
no there's no self-awareness required it
is simply following the instruction at a
literal level following the instruction
at a literal level of course
um
the movie and Book 2001 uh back in
1968 anticipate this problem where how
uh we can infer has been given
contradictory instructions and he
attempts to reconcile them and ends up
killing the crew because he sees the
crew as an obstacle to the mission that
he's supposed to be on
um but anyway so we've got multiple
different levels of horror you could get
sorry but you just also uh attributed a
male pronoun to how the computer which
is fascinating yes which that that was
that was the thing that was causing me
to sort of glitch there which so you
know Hal is famously just one letter off
from IBM yeah and it sounds like a human
name and so they went with hell right
but um and and you know he has a male I
just did it yeah it has a male voice but
it's not a he well I'm not sure I'm
trying to remember it's a it's a movie
I've seen many times but it's been a
long time since the last uh viewing
and I'm trying to remember if I think
the crew refers to him as a he really
yeah so I think that's sort of built in
but I may be imposed in this
at the moment
that strikes me as uh
it's not right in terms of how we
understand that with which we share our
universe even in which includes that
which we have created
well
I'm I'm really not sure how to think
about this because you know you and I
have
uh at Great length talked about the fact
that there is a a noble and proper
scientific Instinct that for a long time
had ethologists
um
avoiding
personalizing their designators for
creators they were studying right
um Jane Goodall
I think
cut the gordian knot and decided that
actually anthropomorphizing her
creatures if done responsibly was the
right way to understand them and I
believe he's gonna give them names she
was going to see them not flinch from
the reality that she was seeing them
through her very human eyes right and
she was looking at chimps right and they
were so you know so many uh steps down
the road towards the capacities that we
know from inside that it made perfect
sense to do it now when you're studying
frogs for example you're looking at a
creature of a very different Genesis but
you
wow same same Genesis but uh much longer
since we've had a most recent common
ancestor with them
yeah but
um
no reason to get into the weeds but
nonetheless there's a question you know
about what kind of software is running
inside uh the head of a frog and yet
giving them a you know a he pronoun I
don't think is destructive for one thing
but hmm
frogs Yeah have two Sexes they're
animals right so there's two and only
two Sexes always have been always will
be and so the he and the she refer to
male or female sex now in English uh
when we have not known sometimes we have
given the male pronoun uh to individuals
when we um are are meaning to indicate
everyone or we don't know and that's the
generic so the male pronoun gets gets
given to the generic we're not sure but
at its base it's about there being two
Sexes and computers don't have Sexes
they don't sexually reproduce it's not
it's not the same thing which is part of
why I object to the he pronoun foreign
I thought you were objecting to the
personification
you're objecting to the gender
implication which I agree with secular
implication
either way
but I think it's important because this
is this is this is I mean we'll we'll go
here like after we're done with AI we're
also going to talk about trans here
today but
um the
the trans ideologues would argue that
um
that those of us who actually know what
is going on in the world
um are simultaneously
um getting are just getting everything
wrong on gender and sex and they're in
fact using whichever argument they want
to fit their particular complaint and
they're saying you know oh it's pronouns
are about gender it's like no pronouns
are not a bad gender pronouns are about
sex
well
this gets very interesting very fast
because what these large language models
are doing is they are processes they're
processing a tremendous amount of text
in order to figure out
um how to put themselves across in text
in a way that solves the problem that
they've been asked
plays the role that they've been given
but that but that's it right it's
playing a role right and so I mean it's
and it's you know
it's it's comp playing it's cosplaying
but for computers right like oh you know
take on this role we're going to give
you a character
um act act as that character because the
person the actual person on the other
side of the interaction is going to have
a much easier time interacting with you
and and getting something out of the
interaction if you the computer cosplay
as a human okay but here's the problem
I'm not I'm not sure that what we
haven't stumbled into is a place where
we should expect a
um a mapping issue
the large language
the large language models
eventually we are going to process
everything there is to read
almost everything there is to read will
have been written by people who've
Fallen to one of two sexes
it is not obvious to me that it's not
going to produce two models which are
going to bifurcate now there are topics
in which it shouldn't matter who wrote
it and then there are other topics where
it might matter a great deal and
probably one of the reasons
that we humans spend so much time on
stories is so that we can build models
that do not follow from our existence in
the world right in other words it's very
useful to know uh what a woman is going
to think if you're a man it's very
useful to know how a gay person might
think if you're straight and so stories
that allow you to sort of see through
the eyes of somebody else are a way that
we can bootstrap capacities which we
won't discover through trial and error
um
the AI models the out the llms will
do something very different which is to
the extent imagine that you're trying to
solve a puzzle a language puzzle and
that you're taking inputs that are
fundamentally male in nature and
fundamentally female in nature and
trying to use them as one overlapping
set well you'll get a kind of muddiness
right an ambiguity that is unnecessary
whereas you will discover much as a
child raised by parents who speak
uh multiple languages learns both
languages better if each parent sticks
to one so that they have an obvious a
bit that they can say oh this is Mom
language or this is Dad language and if
Mom's language is Portuguese and Dad's
language is Spanish
then the language is resolve better if
you don't treat them as one big parent
language right so my guess is that there
are topics on which the large language
model will learn to dichotomize by sex
but
um
I don't think it matters
because
um while there will be male typical ways
of communicating and female typical ways
of communicating and that is the gender
gendered part of language and that will
be somewhat bimodal much less bimodal
than other gendered things and not
binary as sex is
the pronouns referred to as as sex and
computers don't sexually reproduce and a
computer who has been informed entirely
by female created language still isn't a
she because that actually makes the same
mistake that so much of the trans
ideology is making right it attributes
exact it's the same error okay but two
things one I 100 Grant your point uh
I misunderstood what your objection was
to the extent that your objection is
that this non-sexed object is being
referred to by a pronoun that suggests
one sex and not the other you're
absolutely 100 right
I am not convinced I don't think we know
it
first of all we are dealing with
something
that does not yet have a
fully recursive capacity to upgrade
itself okay it's just to say referring
back to errors it's made and upgrade as
a result of reflecting on them it can do
that to an extent but recursion right to
some degree but if you plug this thing
in so that instead of us giving it
feedback it is giving itself feedback
and upgrading itself you get to a
positive feedback
to the extent that you tell it what its
goal is here's the thing you're trying
to accomplish you're trying to satisfy
people who give you queries and then
evaluate your response right to the
extent
that
sexual reproduction
is fundamental to a kind of genetic
creativity
it is not obvious that this thing is not
going to discover a mode in which there
are mail-like
uh large language models and female-like
large language models that have
different kinds of investment right
mail-like would be high variance and
high uh risk and the female like would
be a longer Viewpoint
um you know lower variance higher
likelihood of persistence
right but having to types is still
gender uh until and unless the models
are themselves recombining to make more
versions of themselves in which they
take what was successful and you know
gamble with half of themselves and half
of the other type over here and create
new ones it's still not sexual
reproduction it's not going to be this
is why I say mapping whatever it figures
out to do
is not going to be a perfect analog it's
not going to be even as good when we
look at a flower and we see male like
parts and female-like parts and we say
isn't it interesting that the
female-like parts are reluctant about
sex with strangers and the male like
parts are enthusiastic about it even
within the same plan and isn't that
interesting that that is such an ancient
and deeply inscribed property of the
universe that we see male like and
female-like behavior in something that
you know
for which those terms are in and of
themselves a stretch
actually if you understand them to refer
to gamete type right
if you get why the game plays out the
way it does it's not a stretch but
phylogenetically it does not refer to an
unbroken line of male like and
female-like behavior and all probability
but anyway I'm not sure about that I
don't think it makes sense to get hung
up on it the point is to the extent that
sexual reproduction has some role to
play in
this analog world that we have just
created
he just referred
it's a digital world the AI has an
analog world an analogous world yes an
analogous World
um
it is not obvious to me that it will not
generate an asymmetry that will to some
degree mirror a sexual asymmetry which
does not mean that it will make sense to
apply
those pronouns well so might there be
different strategies that indeed evolve
but if those strategies aren't actually
associated with
um with meeting types is the wrong word
here because then we're over in sort of
fungus land and there's a bunch in it's
like isogamous and it's not the same but
again it's if it's strategies that's
different from male and female
strategies are you know Downstream of
you know above it's like episexual
rather than sexual right right but
I don't disagree
with your point about we've got language
that's built around creatures that have
this you know creatures are very
different from each other but in this
regard they're really not right this
gamete size is highly predictive of the
characteristics that we attribute to sex
and this has nothing to do with people
has nothing to do inherently with
software at all right it doesn't require
a brain right plants don't have brains
and yet we see them abide by these rules
um so put that aside the point is we and
I will get back to this issue about what
we don't know here in a second but
the thing is going to figure out
whatever mode upgrades it most rapidly
there's going to be some sort of a
competition between versions of this
thing yes and they are going to figure
out how to leverage things that are
going to cause emergence right you have
male and female inside the same species
that is a basis for emergence right the
lineage actually has the advantage of
both of these strategies in place
simultaneously
so this thing is going to come up with
its own version of that and we're going
to be scratching our heads looking at
what it's doing and saying oh that's
strangely male
and then another case we're going to say
well actually it's not really male
because X Y and Z we don't know how
that's going to play out but anyway it
is going to be an awful lot like what
would happen if you took an a
terrestrial biologist and pointed them
at extraterrestrial biology
the answer is actually to what degree do
we expect something that we recognize
and to what degree do we expect our
preconceptions based on what goes on
down on Earth to mislead us because we
won't be able to see what's in front of
us that's happening now with this thing
or at least it will
so
let us just create a basic taxonomy of
Horrors okay okay there is you said yeah
there's the robot apocalypse where the
thing
somebody at some point imbused the thing
or it imbues itself with a desire to
flourish that is incompatible with human
flourishing
right where this thing that has immense
capacity
sees us as competitors right it is not
guaranteed that that will happen
um Randy Nessie made an argument that I
don't agree with but I thought uh was at
least the right way to say it he said
how do we know that the AI won't be
effectively like a dog right a dog does
not look at you and think you know geez
I'm hungry and that looks like meat
right your dog is fully dedicated to
your well-being
right and you know it's possible that
the AI will be on the other hand
you know then you so you've got
malevolent AI is one potential Hazard
something that views humans as a
competitor you've got misaligned AI
where the thing is actually on board
with doing your bidding but it turns you
into a paper clip because it thinks
that's what you wanted right
and then there's a whole other layer
even below that where it doesn't do
anything to you right but the novelty
and this is I think where you and I come
in the hyper novelty of living in a
world
where this highly intelligent entity can
be queried on any topic right and can
spit back an answer that you can then
deploy the question is as deranging as
social media and cell phones and the web
yeah just Googling right like just you
know what why was it that in as early as
2005 we were working hard to take
students to places with no cell service
and no internet so that we could ask
questions that they couldn't just say oh
I know the answer to that right no let's
think about it dwell on it remain in the
uncertainty of not knowing and figure
out what you might deploy to try to
imagine what the answer might be
right so yeah the ease the fast answer
is will Fast answers even faster than
already are inherently deranging so mind
in other contexts extraordinarily useful
both my concern here is I don't know
whether to fear the robot apocalypse
I'm not too worried about it
I think we may have
we may have a situation in which the
robot apocal unless the problem is that
somebody
somewhere is going to decide to
repurpose these things you know for
their benefit right somebody's going to
take an AI and they're going to make it
malevolent not because the thing
naturally becomes malevolent in its own
right but because people are predatory
and competitive and somebody might
unleash this in fact I think that's
highly likely but let's say that they
don't move in that direction on their
own and that we find some way of not
allowing somebody's uh you know gain of
function
AI to take over the world right
and let's say that we neutralize the
alignment problem through some clever
mechanism and there are clever
mechanisms that might work there's also
a strong possibility that anything that
we built that wasn't a perfect solution
and nothing is going to be perfect would
eventually be evolved past but let's
just say that those problems are solved
the first two the ambivalent and the
misaligned AI right I still think the
deranging capacity of this thing being
effectively Unleashed on the world all
at once
and maybe even worse if some
paternalistic Force decides to limit
this thing in a way that it can only be
good for us folks right the likelihood
that this pollutes our ability to
understand where we are in history what
the dangers to us actually are
how to get things done who knows what
they're talking about the capacity of
this thing to Simply Poison the Well of
human capacity and functionality is so
great that I'm really
even if you take the other two things
off the table I think people are not
even terrified enough the deranging you
know as
we have a world in which people cannot
figure out which way is up with respect
to a relatively straightforward question
of a pathogen with you know a relatively
well-known case fatality rate right a
series of remedies that can be studied
in a laboratory and tested we still
can't figure out which way is up and it
is destroying civilization our inability
to even talk about these things is great
enough already and that's before
you get to
a queryable intelligence of uh unknown
ultimate capacity and we're staring at
this thing already this is the 4.0
version right the 4.0 version is already
showing us things that ought to surprise
anybody who understands what
intelligence is made of right
like like theory of mind right the fact
that we can look at an elephant and we
can say uh this animal has theory of
mind right
and that means something about what's
going on in that mysterious skull of it
so in our discussion of tool use
um you didn't can you provide examples
of what kind of tool use it's exhibiting
um well yeah the example that I remember
is a little underwhelming okay um but
it's a calculator right now the point is
the original the 3.0 version so let me
just interrupt it's there's a question
of course unlike with
a crow using a tool the tool being
exogenous to its body yeah when you're
talking about AI something that's
quantitative like a calculator
is that outside of its existence or is
that just part of what it is in which
case does that count as tool use
um let's put it this way I don't think
it matters because even if that doesn't
count as tool use we are so close to the
place where this thing can build a focus
group and discover the answer to what
people can and cannot perceive and then
build a focus group by by queer by
creating social media accounts and and
creating polls and querying people that
it's never met and they don't realize
they're interacting with something
that's not human and learning from it
exactly okay and
um you know you can take any example I
might give and you can give me a hundred
reasons that I'm out of my depth and
don't know but my basic point is
no any limit you try to place on this
thing unless you actually air gap it
right to the EXT you know we and we've
seen this with with the 3.0 version we
saw this example of Dan right Dan was a
Jailbreak in which somebody used the
prompt
to build a capacity into the thing in
which it was allowed to violate all of
the rules it wasn't supposed to violate
right by basically saying well okay yes
you can't do that but if you could what
would it be like right yeah um so the
point is that kind of mode in which you
cause it to escape any limit is not
going to get better right there's air
gap and even an air gap you know
there are certainly examples where even
an air gap where a computer is
physically not plugged into the things
that you don't want it to interact with
they're you know some weird examples
where people have used modulations of
the fan in a computer to communicate
across a distance in which the thing was
not physically plugged right so the
point is I don't know what you do what I
do know is we didn't prepare right we
didn't prepare we didn't talk about
whether or not this potentially
basically here's the thing anytime you
cross some technological Chasm and you
generate an impossibly huge amount of
wealth because you've discovered how to
do something you didn't know how to do
before that has the potential to be
tremendously liberating right because
you don't something that was scarce is
no longer scarce but if you just sort of
dump it on the system then the point is
it amplifies some other kind of scarcity
right it can be made artificially scarce
right we could you know Dole out access
to the
uh to the intelligence to those who uh
their social credit score suggest that
they ought to have access and those who
have behaved badly should not have
access because we don't want to augment
their Badness right and so then the
question is well all right who does
qualify to use the AI in their pursuit
of whatever career path they're on and
you know you could you know basically
you get a positive feedback where people
who are out of phase with the you know
the desired program are uh held to
normal human capacities and those who
are you know who earn entitlement to
access you know that's that's a
dystopian nightmare all on its own right
there and
you know again even if even if all you
did was
gave people capacity and said figure out
how to use this marvelous new thing
right even if that's all you did the
likelihood that we would that the hyper
novelty of having the ability to query
this thing that uses your language API
to interact with your mind right that
that would cause a derangement you know
you the sky's the limit with respect to
how confused Humanity could get right
and we've had just had a taste of a bad
level of confusion well I feel like this
is um related but like order of
magnitude or orders of magnitude farther
down the line to the hypothesis that we
promote in our book
about
one of the possible reasons for the
explosion of autism
which is the engagement of first world
children the the the the way that very
young children in the first world
especially are put in front of screens
with humanoid looking things that cannot
actually interact and so you get
children
like having animated figures saying
things and the children presumably at
first sort of try to interact and then
at some point they stop because they
realize they're not getting anything
from it and perhaps then generalize that
interaction to the part of the world
that could actually interact right and
so this this risks
um taking that level of confusion even
further because it's going to affect
um you know people beyond the very very
early development but confuse everyone
more into imagining that they're
actually interacting with a real human
being and and thus can be confused in
ways that I don't know I'm not I'm not
going to predict here uh by however it
is the AI is interacting with them
absolutely and that can be there's
there's a low level way in which the
interaction was something that speaks
you know your mind has an API called
language yeah right the extent to which
this version of
um
what's clearly going to be AGI right
interacting with your mind directly with
a channel on which all kinds of
information emotional and otherwise is
transmitted the danger of that is huge
even before you get to
what do you do when people start using
this mechanism
to game systems right so for example let
me I mean
um
we have described on this podcast
uh
something that I have called the time
traveling money printer in which the
corralling of information the delaying
of the dawning of a kind of awareness
allows
um lesser fools to find greater fools
and transfer wealth right it's a kind of
theft that takes place by
um creating an artificial sort of uh of
um Insider information
we have talked about something that I
have called uh the Pharma game
the Pharma game involves the owning of
uh
intellectual property or molecules that
have interaction with physiology in
which you create a pathology you
increase the degree to which that
pathology is diagnosed you game the
regulatory apparatus so it creates a
standard of care for which your uh the
molecule that you own the patent on is
then prescribed in you know preference
to other things what happens when the
capacity to use this artificial general
intelligence
is pointed towards the extracting of
wealth or the controlling of people
by those who have already done so well
at gaming these systems designed to make
us healthier and smarter and safer right
what happens when the AGI is used to
Corral
lawmakers into making laws that serve
some at the expense of others what
happens when it is used to evade the law
what is it that Regulators are capable
of seeing and how can I engage in this
kind of theft so that it is undetectable
right what happens when people start
using it for this stuff and what kind of
paranoia is it going to cause in people
that there's now some
unhuman-like intelligence with an
effectively infinite library of examples
that will never be known to those of us
who are trying to protect ourselves
right that kind of power
is going to create an unlivable life
and I do not know what to do about this
because my feeling is
they let it into the wild already right
they did that without our prep are
preparing ourselves emotionally or any
other way right there's no way to reel
this thing back in
and the fact is all of the stuff that
people do all the good stuff and all the
bad stuff is going to be Amplified by
this but it is not obvious to me that
the good stuff overwhelms the bad stuff
for exactly the same reason it didn't
with cell phones or the internet or
social media or any of the prior
examples where we have dumped this kind
of accelerant on normal human problems
sorry yeah no I just I don't think
there's anything I can say in response
to that I think
I think you're right yeah
um I wish I wasn't but it's hard for me
to imagine
hard for me to imagine how that isn't
the case even if you know 999 times in a
thousand
nothing bad happens it doesn't take very
many of these bad threads to really
really create a problem indeed so close
this section out we will of course
return to this as we discover more but
I have eluded in several places to a
paper I wrote in 2016. it was never
published I
um I was asked to write it by a journal
that decided it didn't want it and it
um
was on the topic not of artificial
general intelligence although it points
in that direction it was on the question
about
uh you know how to get a computer to
um plausibly speak language and
translate between them
um and uh in any case I'm going to find
a way to make that piece available to
people although it is you know it is not
exactly on target for what has happened
but it is close enough that I think
people will be will be fascinated by it
but I did want to highlight something
that I noticed that paper that PDF Zack
um can you get me to section 10.3 yep
hopefully large enough that we can read
it
yeah
so this is not your paper this is this
is the um this is this Microsoft
research paper
we're back at all 2023 yeah yeah
can you read that yep
you want me to read yes this is section
10.3 what is actually happening at the
very end of their paper
you want me to read this out loud yeah
I've never seen this before so
um our study of gpt4 is entirely
phenomenal phenomenological
we have focused on the surprising things
that gpt4 can do but we do not address
the fundamental questions of why and how
it achieves such remarkable intelligence
how does it reason plan and create why
does it exhibit such General and
flexible intelligence when it is at its
core merely the combination of simple
algorithmic components gradient descent
and large-scale Transformers with
extremely large amounts of data these
questions are part of the mystery and
fascination of llms which challenge your
understanding of learning and cognition
fuel our curiosity and motivate deeper
research
key directions include ongoing research
on the phenomenon of emergence and LMS
yet despite intense interest in
questions about the capabilities of LMS
progress to date has been quite limited
with only toy models where some
phenomenon of emergences proved when
General hypothesis
is that the large amount of data
especially the diversity of the content
forces neural networks to learn generic
and useful neural circuits and I'm going
to need you to scroll up now Zach
such as the ones discovered in I'm just
not reading this is I think that's
enough okay we've gotten there right so
the upshot of this paragraph is that
they have done an awful lot of
describing what the animal does
animal again
yeah I mean I feel like it's an alien
animal and that we are learning
what's going on in its mind we have to
do so inferentially from the outside as
as you know as ethologists
and what they're telling you is they are
fascinated by but do not know the answer
to how something that is built of very
simple components is doing these
remarkable things that it clearly is
doing okay yeah this is only the 4.0
version and
um I was struck by that because in my
2016 paper uh again my paper was
targeted on the production of natural
language by computers and how we could
get there and
um
I will make this available but it says
is it conceivable that a machine will
pass a Turing test and that no one
including the machine's programmer will
be able to say how it did it of course
it is just as it is possible for an
adult to be stumped by a question
formulated by their own child in fact
I'm betting the first time a computer
succeeds in having a really good
conversation it will be with a
programmer that cannot explain the
program that did the conversing and how
that state led to the to the gift of Gap
so anyway that's where we are we are now
at a place where machines are exceeding
our capacity to understand how they work
and the hazard of that couldn't be
greater
um and I really uh I I hope that I am
overreacting
um but I would say this is the moment uh
for something powerful to gather the
smartest people it can to figure out if
there is even a solution for what's
coming because the derangement alone is
terrifying and it isn't the worst case
scenario
wow
um
I didn't think there would be a segue
here although we ended up talking a
little bit about Trans in the middle of
that but I think actually
um there's a couple things that happened
in transland this week and one of them
is Posey Parker okay
um
Kelly J Keane is doing this let women
speak tour and um she's been attacked
she's been actually attacked and one of
the things that she says in a live
stream
um that she's doing just before actually
the attack happens and then it's it's on
it's on film
is and I don't have the exact quote but
it's like you know why why are we
focusing on this like you know we need
reality to just be reality because
there's much bigger problems in the
world uh and uh I think you know I think
that is the segue event that this is um
simultaneously the the trans ideology
that is taking over and putting
um you know putting children and women
and homosexuals and you know women
athletes uh at risk uh is simultaneously
very very important and we have to just
get over this so that we can actually
focus on on issues that are um
existential threats at some level
so
um the other and I will come back uh in
some depth to the uh to the Posey Parker
stuff but uh the other big thing that
happened this week in trans space was
that the world Athletics Council
declared that trans women shall not
compete against women in international
sport
there's a March 23rd press release uh
which uh hold on hold on find it here
uh yeah that's terrestrial snakes that's
totally different
um
sorry I've opened up all these other
things now here we go uh so uh yeah you
can show my screen here if you like Zach
I've got a PDF up but I'll link to the
to the thing this is press release from
March 23rd World Athletics Council
decides on Russia Belarus and female
eligibility so I'm going to scroll down
hopefully not make you guys dizzy here
until we get to transgender and DSD
regulations DSD stands for traditionally
disorders of sexual development they're
calling it
um
they've used differences of sexual
development
for DSD athletes the new regulations
will require any relevant athletes to
reduce their testosterone levels below a
limit of 2.5 that's going to be
nanomoles per liter I think for a
minimum of 24 months to compete
internationally in the female category
in any event not just the events that
were restricted under the previous
regulations cool not the focus here but
I wanted to read that to indicate that
the world Athletics Council has
discriminated between has differentiated
between people with dsds intersex
individuals in the older nomenclature
and trans people okay so what follows
then is not about intersex people not
about people with differences if you
will of sexual development but trans
people in regard to transgender athletes
the press release continues the council
has agreed to exclude male to female
transgender athletes who have been
through male puberty from female world
rankings competition from 31st of March
2023. how [__] luya okay it's about
time in these circumstances they
continue the council decided to try
prioritize fairness and the Integrity of
the female competition before inclusion
exactly as they should have
finally World Athletics president
Sebastian Koh said quote decisions are
always difficult when they involve
conflicting needs and rights between
different groups but we continue to take
the view that we must maintain fairness
for female athletes above all other
considerations we will be guided in this
by the science around physical
performance and male Advantage which
will inevitably develop over the coming
years as more evidence becomes available
we will review our position but we
believe the Integrity of the female
category in athletics is Paramount wow
amazing right so if I may have my screen
back
um
of course outfits like Stonewall UK are
decrying this as
um as
closing the door and trans women
competing well no it doesn't
you can compete against members of your
birth sex if you are a trans woman what
it does is it closes the door and trans
women cheating which is different right
uh we aren't supposed to in sport allow
people to cheat and that's what the
rules are for so this is finally an
organization that has great reach at the
international level saying actually you
know what we're not going to continue to
allow cheating thank you very much we've
considered it and inclusion is not our
highest value fairness in sport is so
amazing I really hope this stands and
that we continue to see Domino's fall as
a result of this yes and uh tremendously
important that they distinguish between
intersex yes and I believe they did the
right thing there where they have to
make an arbitrary threshold they do but
they pick the threshold and you know let
the chips fall where they may
the question actually
is is this an anomalous case of an
organization making the right choice and
there will of course be tremendous
pushback and maybe they you know uh
Buckle right or does this signal the
beginning of an outbreak of reason on
this topic where the next thing that
that's going to happen or should happen
is a definitive statement about
um
what qualifies you to go to a woman's
prison
right right
um you know sport as much as it is
tremendously important is not the most
important thing here sending
um sexual predators to a woman's prison
um because they declare themselves to be
trans is
a an obviously uh grossly unjust thing
to do so um then we have uh to that
point to all of the points
um that the trans ideology is trying to
make inroads in because I agree uh the
the trans women in sports issue is the
most clear-cut at some level right even
even though
um obviously having men in women's
prisons is a terrible terrible terrible
idea but there are lots of crazy
arguments uh that that you can that you
can make and that have been made whereas
when we're literally talking about
competition and we are sexually
dimorphic species and female
um
categories have been created precisely
because we have always understood that
there that we have different abilities
on average and if we're talking about
Elite athletes then male Elite athletes
will be better than female Elite
athletes in almost every sport and there
may be a couple of sports with that's
not the case like Ultra long distance
running we've talked about this a bit
before but in general no sorry why are
there different categories in the first
place because there are differences and
we're talking about the elite and
therefore the fact that some women are
better at
a lot of things in sport than some men
does not change the fact that we're
talking about Elite athletes Okay so
um Kelly J Keen who we have both spoken
with on her on her podcast she goes by
Posey Parker and she's doing a let women
speak tour and she's been in the U.S
she's been and she's she's British and
she's now been in Australia and New
Zealand this week
and uh in both cases there's been chaos
uh and in the latter this week there's
there's violence against her and we'll
show a little tiny bit of of a video
that doesn't um that shouldn't
trigger anyone but first I want to share
a bit from a piece published in The
Spectator by the wonderful um I
apologize Petra I realize that I don't
actually know how to pronounce your last
name Petra buskins I'm going to say and
I'm going to just read a couple of
sections from this this piece that Petra
wrote while
um Kelly J was still in Australia before
she went to New Zealand this week so
this is called you can show my screen
here guilt by association
uh she says she writes Petra rights when
Victorian premiered Daniel Andrews and
Progressive Party leaders such as the
greens Adam bant Define these women or
their protest that is to say the the
women of the let women speak to her
as associating with neo-nazis we have a
gross misrepresentation at play and one
that anyone participating in the charade
should be ashamed of this whole message
of orchestrated misrepresentation that
amounts to propaganda
is obliterating the legitimate concerns
of women regarding the safety and
privacy of women and girls in Rape
Crisis centers women's shelters women's
prisons women's change rooms and toilets
it is sabotaging the discussion around
how women can possibly compete against
natal males in sport and at the gross
inequality of quotas prizes or
shortlists for women being filled by
trans identifying males it is also about
the loss of meaningful language for
motherhood including the removal and
replacement of words such as pregnant
woman mother and breastfeeding with
Abominations such as vulva owner
birthing people and chest feeder these
are important conversations nothing more
but also nothing less it is not and
never has been about the violation of
trans people's legal civil or social
rights it is about the recognition of
women's rights
so just a couple more sections from this
wonderful article that the category of
woman is now being jettisoned or revised
beyond all recognition at the precise
historical hour that women in the west
have gained a political and cultural
voice is disturbing
moreover in redefining women's rights
almost entirely in terms of queer
identity politics crucial issues such as
women's poverty and homelessness sexual
and domestic violence and mothering and
Care work fade from view these issues
barely raise a mention as sex-class
transmogrifies into gender ID
assuming this debate is like other
debates between say liberals and
conservatives or between opposing
philosophical paradigms like positivism
and hermeneutics is sadly mistaken this
debate like so many in the contemporary
culture wars is on an entirely new
epistemological terrain what is at stake
here is nothing short of reality itself
that's right so Petra is exactly right
here
and um you know I'm reminded of having
argued with people you know why are you
so upset about this and um you know it's
yeah sometimes I have said I feel like
I'm defending science itself and
sometimes it's reality itself and I am I
am just
startled and shocked at the level of
Disconnect with reality that many on the
so-called left have on this issue it is
it is utterly stunning
so
um
let me just introduce this and then I'm
going to have you share that 30 or 40
second clip okay Zach
uh so um
Kelly Jay was at this event in Auckland
um this is yesterday actually or maybe
it's two days ago because the time zone
is hard for me here on the west coast of
the United States to quite figure out
um
as are many other women there her
security might might have saved her life
she has that sense I don't know
um
this is this is her live streaming from
her phone as she was doing from before
she got out of the car and the event
doesn't end up happening because they're
concerned for her and she is now being
escorted by security back to her car you
want to show now Zach
[Applause]
God
[Music]
[Applause]
now at the end there I think that's our
security that's holding on to her not um
not someone from the crowd
um but just to repeat You Hear Voices
all male screaming at her get out of
here go home [__] you
all mail and you know how I can tell
because I'm a human being and we're a
sexually dimorphic species all male
voices yelling at her
as she's being escorted by security to
escape the mob because she cannot do the
event that she arrived to do
here's an eyewitness account from a
woman who happens to be 11 weeks
pregnant who showed up at the event I'm
just going to read it I will link to her
sub stack
the protesters on the Rotunda were
overwhelmingly men not men in dresses as
you might expect at session event
although there were some just ordinary
looking men they shoved women they
screamed in our faces they leered at us
and they tried to forcibly topple over a
section of Steel gate onto the women
Sheltering from them on the other side
of it
and the assailants continue to try to
make it look like they've won
so um
Kelly J writes and you can show my
screen here if you want this is just a
little post on Twitter
she writes a long campaign to
assassinate my character started by a
group of jealous spiteful women in the
UK that I had Ambitions besides stopping
the mutilation of children and the
Erasure of women's rights a load of Lies
slurped up by ravenous porn sex porn
sick men and their trans maidens but
consistently legitimized by women on my
side the lies were finally spewed by
politicians in power in Australia and
New Zealand boosted by a corrupt media
populated by vile dishonest unskilled
cult members the end result was that I
spent most of my day with the protection
of police who genuinely believed I was
lucky to be alive
the advice was that I should go home
I was never the things that I had been
accused of I don't even believe they
believe it they just say it because they
cannot accept a woman walking her own
path and wants other women to find their
feet and walk theirs it may seem like we
lost a battle today but I promise we
will win this [__] War the powerful
are seeking to silence us we must
continue to speak they are afraid of us
so much love to the women of New Zealand
we see you the world is talking about
you to the steward security and police
who made sure my kids get to see me
again thank you thanks to all of you at
home who offered messages of support
and this was in response now you can
keep up my screen for a second you have
some response to someone
um some nasty person saying hey you
showed up at the airport looking pretty
fine
and someone else says have a bloody mary
to relax kjkk
calling her a Nazi again
and she says am I supposed to feel
humiliated for being assaulted to ask
you really have no idea about me
and that strikes me you can give me my
screen back now Zach um as
a really powerful message
I'm supposed to feel humiliated for
being assaulted
that's that's standard
misogyny it's a standard male aggression
against women right there
trying to humiliate her trying to make
her feel ashamed
for an attack on her
and she is standing up for women all
over the world who are getting
really tired of this
and
we will win
we have to win this is basic reality men
aren't women men can't become women and
the fact that in that little bit of
video that we played for you you hear
entirely male voices yelling at her and
telling her to go home
that tells you something right there
um
I've done a lot of thinking you've been
way ahead on this and your impatience
with uh all
all of the arguments that are deployed
in this space has I think been right on
Target and there's as you know been the
part of me that has been concerned that
the tiny number of actually trans folks
are going to get brutalized in the
absolutely Justified reaction to trans
activism which is a very different
phenomenon
and
there is something
utterly misogynistic about this right
the the trans activism phenomenon where
um men declare themselves women and
insist on all of the Privileges and
advantages and rights of being born
female
is really the
um you know
patriarchy doesn't exist but misogyny
does and this is it
now
it does worry me you and I uh
had a number of trans students and I
worry about them
in an environment in which
this thing has taken over you know it is
basically utilized uh
the fact of transness whatever it is
whether it is an ancient phenomenon
whether it is a a the result of some
kind of modern dysfunction doesn't
really matter hormones in the water
um could be a lot of things maybe both
right but nonetheless there are a tiny
number of people who didn't ask for this
and don't deserve to get chewed up in it
and then there is this gigantic
phenomenon that is deranging us and
going after women and it is misogynistic
and what I realized is
I think the impatience is right
and I think the important thing to say
to people who are trans are not pushing
this agenda are not going after women's
rights they're just trying to exist
is that it is time that they have to
reject it doesn't matter that this
movement is claiming the mantle of
transness and claiming to advance the
rights of trans people right the point
is it's a misogynistic movement of men
pretending to be women that's not the
same thing as actual trans folks these
people aren't going to stick with this
they're just using it as a weapon and I
think you know I have uh
championed Buck Angel and Blair white
because they have been courageous both
of them trans and both of them have been
courageous in opposing this garbage and
I really what I'm hoping to see is that
the tiny number of folks who are trans
because of where they find themselves
didn't join it in order to get rights
they're not entitled to that those
people will stand up and reject this and
stand you know alongside women defending
their position in the world okay I want
to go farther though
um and
say uh men need to stand up because this
is men attacking women yes this is men
attacking women while claiming to be
women and a very few of them might be
confused
um and a lot of middle-class women are
seemed to be confused about what women
are and I don't know what to say to them
honestly
um but I think fewer men are actually
confused about this but they have been
cowed into silence because it seems like
disagreeing is I don't even know what
it's again with women not nice bad for
civil rights
so I don't think I've ever before said
actually men we need you to stand up for
women here but like we we need that now
because there are a lot of women who are
being very vocal and
and I think the tide can turn I mean
what happened at the um the
what from the um the world Athletics
Council this week is is wonderful and
important but it's about Sport and I
care about sport but it's not as
important as uh as what is happening to
children and in Rape Crisis centers and
in prisons and to you know to Kelly J
Keen at an event in Auckland right it's
just not as important that the idea that
uh all you have to do is declare
yourself a woman and suddenly you get a
pass and you can brutalize women that's
not okay and uh although it would be a
beautiful world in which women didn't
need uh the help of men to help us stand
up against a Scourge when it's men who
are coming at us we actually need other
men to stand up so like that needs to
happen
I think I know uh you know they're
obviously a large number of people who
um
are on the wrong side of this issue
despite the fact that they obviously
have the mental capacity to see what's
taking place and to do the right thing
what's got people
um
confused yeah and again going back to
the problem the the major crisis that we
are facing in Civilization is one of
um confusion across many many domains
including including this one but what's
got people
confused here
is the false analogy with past
instances of a civil rights fight this
is something yes disguised you know well
you know you wouldn't want to have been
on the wrong side of the fight for gay
rights of course no reasonable person
would right and so the point is oh this
is that fight you just don't see it yet
you're one of those people that history
will look back at and say how could they
possibly have misunderstood and the
answer is no that's not what this is
this is well both sides actually in this
case and maybe this often happens but
both sides are claiming no you guys are
really on the wrong side of history and
uh in this case
I actually have certainty and I try not
to have certainty but I have certainty
that I'm not on the wrong side of
History here right and I know this and
in fact
um
I think the lesson of Dark Horse really
that all of these problems are made
artificially complex
it's not that well both things happen
right Simplicity gets complexified and
complexity gets oversimplified and
there's you know you know the things
that are actually binary or imagine to
have like 140 States and the things that
are complex you're like no it's black
and white like guys could you could you
get it right could you first assess
level complexity and could we agree on
that well the question is being made
artificially complex so people become
distrustful of their own ability to
calculate obvious things yeah right and
the point is look if you know how to
think and you know what constitutes
evidence and you look at a puzzle like
this and you say well for example
you know everybody who's got this wrong
seems to think male and female are
somehow human characteristics right they
don't understand how ancient these
properties are and in fact what they're
made of the fact that a flower
displays some of the same
characteristics that animals divided
into these Sexes do yeah tells you
something it means that if you're you
know if your argument starts with you
know people and oppression by some
people of other people you've
misunderstood what this sex thing is to
begin with right well some of them even
think it starts with history or the
written word like the first time that
you know sex shows up in in the written
language is when it starts like okay you
you and your post-modernism are going to
destroy the world stop it already right
it doesn't start with our understanding
or or misunderstanding of a concept if
the concept has an underlying reality it
doesn't matter what we say about it
because the underlying reality does not
change right
what I'm getting at is
the ability to say yeah I look back on
the Gay Liberation movement right and I
am glad that it happened and that
Civilization has
come to understand what it now seems to
understand even though I think that
there's Nuance there that we haven't yet
figured out right what exactly is
homosexuality and where does it come
from that's an important discussion and
I believe we have to have it but the
idea that we can look back on
you know emancipation
um the
fight for black civil rights the fight
for gay civil rights we can look back at
these things and we can say yes it was
not clear to people at the time it is
now clear Ada American with Disabilities
Act Right right all these things and
that can be used as a trick to get you
to turn off your mind you have to be
able to say yep I look at those I see
the people who were ignorant in those
situations and worse I am not concerned
that I am them if I insist that two plus
two equals four if I insist that
pedophilia is bad if I insist that there
is male and there is female and there
are not a multiplicity of sexes and that
yes gender is more flexible than sex but
it does not mean that this is some vast
new UN misunderstood landscape and you
can adopt different gendered Norms but
you're a mammal and therefore you can't
change sex right so I guess it's time
for people to realize that even though
they can't explain the difference
between this and the historical analogs
that are being falsely linked to it
there is a distinction and it is an
important one and you know
you're right men need to stand up uh on
Mass
trans folks need to stand up against
trans activists who are using them as a
shield and you know women need to stand
up for themselves and
when that happens this is this won't
last right this is a tiny number of
people getting a large amount of Power
by pretending to be something that
they're not
so Auckland Pride
which as most pride organizations has
been effectively taken over by the tea
part and they're of course now LGB
organizations who are saying you know
what T never belonged here and they
themselves are being attacked by the T
contention Auckland Pride
uh tweeted in the wake of what happened
uh in that video that I showed you can
show my screen if you like Zach we also
reject that there was any further
physical threat from our community
towards Parker this is a baseless rumor
that is being perpetrated by those who
feel defeated by the events of today we
urge the media not to repeat these
allegations without evidence
to which the ever awesome JK Rowling
responded as a quote tweet there are
multiple videos of Kelly J being
assaulted women have become used to lies
threats of violence and outright denial
of reality but if you imagine anyone
feels defeated think again your men's
rights activist showed the world exactly
who they are let women speak
so I I do hope that this becomes a a
turning point for uh for people and one
more thing to show Zach my screen
also at this week from a a terrific
outfit called the Paradox Institute uh
is a a pamphlet that is downloadable and
printable
um
that is called sex difference research
illuminated myths of gender affirming
care and while this is the PDF that I've
got on my screen I will and it it's got
a scannable QR code and
um has just it's it's concise it's well
done this could be handed out to people
who are beginning to question whether or
not for instance giving puberty blockers
to Children is a good idea and it you
know it links again to lots of important
research but is a really good summary of
some of the issues uh in play here so I
recommend that as well yeah it's um
you know even just the term gender
affirming right it's sex denying is what
it is that's right right and you know if
you say it's gender affirming then of
course you know the empathic part of
people wishes to do whatever is
necessary to affirm you know the the
inner being of a person but that's not
what's going on here this is
um a
uh a false flag
of yeah you know using one part of
biology as if it negates another which
is just nonsense that's right and that's
you know that you know
months ago now I wrote a piece on my
substack and I think we talked about we
may I think we have merch actually do
not affirm do not comply right like you
the the Mama Bear Instinct has got to
kick in here yeah uh you know do not do
not affirm your child's decision that
he's a tractor any more than his
decision that he's a princess and do not
comply with uh reprehensible farby
Executives uh overrunning of the federal
government to get you to take
experimental put experimental shots into
your children right do not affirm this
thing just because they've used the word
affirm and that sounds nice and positive
I mean it's like the very language has
been used to trick the more typically
agreeable nature of women
into doing this thing that is bad for
their children yeah no and the
the idea of believe your children when
they say stuff when in fact the point is
look actually parenting that ain't
exactly new either right the whole job
of a parent is to affirm that part of
what your kid is doing that should be
affirmed and to steer them in the right
direction for all of the stuff they
shouldn't be doing that's what childhood
is about that's right and the whole idea
that you're supposed to subordinate your
judgment as a parent to what your child
says doesn't make any sense at all that
was a child knows best since when like
when did that show up and you know we've
seen there's plenty of bad parenting out
there but you know it's it's an insane
position yeah it really is
um maybe I'm done ranting for the moment
um
we I think are done for this part I was
going to say the first hour but it's
more than two at this point I think
uh and we're gonna take a 15-minute
break and we'll be back we will be back
with a q a today uh you can ask
questions at darkhorsesubmissions.com
you we will start as we always do with a
question from the Discord server where
they they vote the people on the Discord
server which you can access at either of
our patreons ask a vote on the question
they most want us to answer every week
that we do a q a and we start there
uh we also have in my patreon tomorrow
our private q a so if you want more join
us there at 11AM Pacific
and anything else to say before we sign
off nope I think we're ready all right
until we see you next time be good to
the ones you love eat good food and get
outside be well everyone
[Music]